printers are the worst of the worst they
struggle to connect to the Wi-Fi they
constantly have paper jams and don't get
me started on the ludicrous price of ink
it's easy to blame the printer industry
as a whole and say that printer
companies are simply unimaginative and
not Innovative but the issue with
printers is a lot more deep rooted than
uninspired companies and lackluster
products the real reason printers are so
crappy is due to Decades of hyper focus
on maximizing Revenue through one Avenue
Inc and it's not uncommon for printering
to exceed at 80 per ounce for
perspective even if human blood only
costs 17 per ounce and silver costs 34
dollars per ounce in fact selling ink is
so profitable that it accounted for 63
percent of all of hpings profits in
2019.